el pasado 9 de febrero el presidente de
Nicaragua Daniel Ortega expulsó del país
a más de 200 presos políticos y los
envió en avión a Estados Unidos El
mandatario dijo que lo hizo para librar
al país de criminales pero Estados
Unidos lo interpretó como un paso
constructivo hacia la mejora de los
Derechos Humanos los presos políticos
liberados incluyen a cinco excandidatos
presidenciales entre otros hoy nos
acompaña John serna quien es un liberado
nicaragüense líder estudiantil que pasó
a la mayoría de su tiempo en celdas de
castigos llamada el Infiernillo yo
gracias por estar en directo a América
un placer hablar con usted y cuéntenos
por favor si usted tuvo voz en su salida
de Nicaragua Cómo fue ese abandono del
país
en alrededor de un trámite de 12 horas
nosotros dejamos máxima seguridad
alrededor de la noche hora Nicaragua
Luego fuimos traslado a otro penal y
durante el transcurso hemos llevado
hacia el aeropuerto
a través de la fuerza aérea a esto de la
de la mañana
durante
estábamos en unos buses
y
nos hicieron nos pusieron en frente un
papel donde decía que estábamos de
acuerdo con salir a y en un espacio en
Blanco sin siquiera decirnos nada
esta gente
Era firmar el papel en blanco y luego
llegar al área de aduana donde nos
esperaba la gente de la Embajada
Americana y el departamento de estado
para lograr verificar nuestros datos
porque ellos ya habían recibido nuestros
pasaportes Entonces era solo el pre
chequeo médico para poder abordar el
avión y ellos nos han preguntado si
nosotros queremos o quisimos salir hacia
Estados Unidos
una vez hemos dejado la prisión
sin embargo en todo ese transcurso
abordamos a las seis y media de la
mañana ahora Nicaragua y con anticipo no
sabíamos Hacia dónde iríamos por tanto
quieren ver de que
todo el tiempo estuvo viciado nosotros
dejamos en las instalaciones de máxima
seguridad luego siendo parte de un
colectivo un poco más general porque
nosotros estuvimos lado la mayor parte
del tiempo incluso este yo había tenido
una visita de mi familia el día anterior
a nuestra salida
y
nadie nadie podría decir de que
esperábamos este este movimiento tan
brusco es que fue sorpresivo
fue muy sorpresivo mire normalmente uno
no pregunta estas cosas en entrevistas
pero yo quiero saber usted cómo está
Cómo se siente Cuál es su situación
física y emocional después de estos días
en los que ha habido tantos cambios y
tan extraños
en primera instancia agradecido con el
gobierno de los Estados Unidos por
acogernos por realizar
tantas gestiones a través del
departamento de estado para poder
negociar nuestro traslado
y en cuanto a nivel físico en cuanto a
nivel emocional y todo el tiempo se
dieron a la tarea de querer quebrantar
nuestro espíritu sin embargo
yo ya esperaba que ocurriera esto porque
diez días antes de que
nos saquen de la prisión ellos siguieron
el mismo patrón durante la amnistía en
los 19 entonces
alguien que ya había vivido eso porque
yo caí preso en febrero 28 2020 me
indicó de que
ese era la señal Más directa para
nuestra Liberación
bien usted se ha mantenido muy activo
pese a todo lo que le ha ocurrido ayer
estaba leyendo una de sus columnas en el
faro y quería preguntarle Pues cuál es
su impresión después de toda esta
situación porque no se ve una
perspectiva de un pronto regreso a su
país pero qué considera usted que sigue
ahora en este camino
por el momento
aprovechar la oportunidad de que tenemos
que nos han brindado
y tratar de reunirnos nuevamente con
nuestra familia porque luego de
nuestra salida hay un largo camino de
por medio donde empieza un proceso de
recuperación en todas las facetas
posibles Mientras tanto es necesario
restablecer vínculos y el trabajo que
hay respecto a las personas que uno
quedaron prisión dos
las fiestas de las personas que hemos
dejado el país tres
establecer parámetros bajo el cual por
ejemplo
podamos llegar a un punto medio
y a pesar de tanta de tantos desacuerdos
porque incluso este esta etapa donde yo
caí preso era en una pandemia
y
la manera en que ellos procedieron
Entonces Siempre fue una mentira montada
y el bono demográfico que tiene
Nicaragua para tomar las decisiones
entonces
Quienes más han sido afectados a estas
alturas han sido las personas más
jóvenes sin embargo
la dirigencia
mediática ha sido tomada a través de
gente mayor y eso no le ha permitido de
llegar a a un acuerdo entre todos Mira
yo uno de los casos que llaman la
atención es el del obispo Rolando
Álvarez que la noticia que nos llegó
internacionalmente Es que se negó a
abandonar el país y un día después fue
condenado a más de 26 años de prisión el
Papa Francisco expresó preocupación por
qué no se fue Rolando usted sabe algo de
ese caso qué opina de la decisión del
obispo de quedarse
Sí lo que pasa es que incluso
alguien que estaba a punto de abordar el
avión no quiso firmar el papel sin
siquiera le dijeran este Hacia dónde iba
Entonces al final esta persona no abordó
al avión en el caso de
monseñor Álvarez
estuvo completamente aislado y él no iba
a dejar el país Yo recuerdo o un domingo
mientras yo estuve preso hace alrededor
de un año que él indicaba de que nacimos
para ser libre cosa muy ajena a todo lo
que hago
debido a que por ejemplo yo recuerdo que
cuando empezó esta lucha mi papá me
indicaba un cuento de Iván illis escrito
por León
que en resumidas era un tipo que quiso
componer el mundo y
no pudo máster terminó exiliado
básicamente eso se volvió un déjà Vu
para mí el día de hoy